as a cosmologist
what's your intuition about whether
there is or isn't intelligent life out
there
uh outside of our own yeah i would say
i'm one of the pessimists
in that i i don't necessarily think that
we're the only ones in the observable
universe which goes out you know
roughly 14 billion years in light travel
time and
more like you know 46 billion years when
you take into account the expansion of
space so
the diameter of our observable universe
is something like you know 90 92 billion
light years
that encompasses you know 100 billion to
a trillion galaxies
with you know 100 billion stars each so
now you're talking about something like
10 to the 22nd
10 to the 23rd power stars and roughly
an equal number of
earth-like planets and so on um
so there there there may well be uh
other intelligent life
but your senses our galaxy's not teeming
with life yeah our galaxy our milky way
galaxy with
several hundred billion stars and and
potentially habitable planets is not
teeming with intelligent life
intelligent yeah i wouldn't
well i'll get to the primitive life the
bacteria in a moment but um
you know we we may well be the only ones
in our milky way galaxy
at most a handful i'd say but i'd
probably
side with the school of thought that
suggests
we're the only ones in our own galaxy
just because
i don't see human intelligence
as being a natural evolutionary path
for life um i mean there's a there's a
number of arguments first of all there's
been
more than 10 billion species of life on
earth in its
history yes uh nothing has approached
our level of intelligence and mechanical
ability and curiosity
you know whales and dolphins appear to
be reasonably intelligent
but there's no evidence that they can
think abstract thoughts that they're
curious about the world they certainly
can't
build machines with which to study the
world um
so that's one argument secondly
we came about as early hominids only
four or five million years ago and as
homo sapiens only about a quarter of a
million years ago
so for the vast majority of the history
of life on earth
an intelligent alien zipping by earth
would have said there's nothing
particularly intelligent
or mechanically able on earth okay
thirdly it's not clear that our
intelligence
is a long-term evolutionary advantage
now it's clear that in the last 100
years 200 years we've improved the lives
of
millions hundreds of millions of people
but at the risk of
potentially destroying ourselves either
intentionally or unintentionally or
through neglect as we discussed before
that's a really
interesting point which is it's possible
that they're
a huge amount of intelligent
civilizations have been born
even through our galaxy but they live
very briefly
and they don't flash bulbs
that brings me to the fourth the fourth
issue
you